so next game against professors
from Sweden okay B3 well,
last time I played such a
strange setup with B6 and C5 let's
see where we
come in here, all sorts of things are
possible, a
bit ambitious maybe, but well I'll
try  I can
manage D6 knight D7 and G6 well, he plays very
reservedly, so that should probably
work. I would have more concerns if
he tried to open up runner D3 E4 or something so quickly.
That should actually
be okay now, so not great in any way or anything,
but at least not like that  As if you
can refute it, well, what does he have now? Typical
moves are yes, C4 or A4. He
did A4, yes, good. A5 is a positional
threat. I have to use A6 in order to be able to do B5 on A5
I now know great here what
does E4 is not a brilliant
structure for him either so I can definitely
make a few more reinforcement moves C4 is rather
interesting h the queen is good for it on C7
yes I think he should
play C4 okay just do it
nothing so good, he'll probably do
bishop
G2 now, yeah, I don't know, he doesn't do anything C4
could still
play. The question is, can I do D5 myself,
so I can anyway, well I'll do
D5 if he
doesn't do anything then I'll gain a bit of
space
Here E5 would of course also have been
considered, but I thought he
could maybe move next to E4
and
seal everything off, then it's
not a
special thing
A5 okay, let's go
B5 now he's taking that
route, yes I don't really understand where
he's going with it  but it
's a good question,
no, yes, that's actually a
natural
move, it pushed back a bit,
maybe bishop E5, but can you
just
go back with C8, yes, that's a very
strange move. I now move knight 7,
then he has to do more here
I think he beats bishop F4, comes E5
and F4 doesn't work at all,
yes, or something like that, so good then
he just gave me the bishop par
when I play with C7 now
he plays F4, maybe knight
E4 is good too, yes of course knight  E4
looks good, takes it, it's
probably
bad, so it won't work at all and I
might have knight C3 a nice
field, yes,
in the long term, that's almost a
winning position. I don't see any smart
move at all, so he has to go back passively now,
yes, probably knight 5
or
so if I now play with C7
then he has to do the very
strange Z Queen D4 or or
give up the quality well since he doesn't
have a black bishop anymore I
think I can also
take it out E5 hangs twice what should he
play knight  G4 still looks like
a trick Knight G4 A1 Queen A1
dr okay given up yes good okay he's
now also losing materialeer is
at least absolutely terrible if he
now loses Queen D4 probably
also material I can play F6 E5
terrible yes yes of course he has that
treated strangely, above all,
incredibly
passively